hey friends and welcome back to Deep
dive for the weekly podcast where it's
my immense pleasure to sit down with
entrepreneurs and authors and academics
and creators and other inspiring people
and we find out how they got to where
they are and the strategies and tools we
can learn from them to help them build a
life that we love this episode is the
end of season 6 of the podcast we have
been live and active for about two years
now I think just over two years which is
awesome and the podcast has been growing
a lot so thank you so much to everyone
who has subscribed to the channel on
YouTube or is listening on podcast
platforms or is sharing it with friends
and this month that's just passed August
2023 has been our biggest month ever in
in terms of downloads so that's really
really amazing to see and a huge thank
you to everyone who's also part of our
telegram Community the Deep divers this
is a totally free telegram Community
where we post the behind the scenes of
what's going on in the podcast and when
we have particular guests coming on
we'll Post in the telegram community and
get questions from the audience on
Telegram and then I'll ask the guest
those questions that we collect from the
telegram community so if you're
interested in joining that it's
completely free there will be a link in
the video description or in the show
notes but this is our somewhat usual end
of season wrap-up episode so we've
talked about so much stuff this season
we've talked about perfectionism
Financial Freedom writing advice viice
how to build a business we've talked
about mental health we've talked about
setting goals we've talked about
manifestation even but one thing that's
particularly stood out for me this
season is the number of skills that the
guests seem to have that they've shared
with us here on the podcast and so in
this Rand up episode I want to share
five of the top skills that I've
personally learned from the guests this
season for each one I'll give a little
bit of an introduction and then we'll
play the relevant segment from that
podcast episode so if for whatever
reason you might have missed every
single episode of this season or even if
you've been very kind enough to listen
to them all you'll hopefully get some
value from this episode because this is
a reminder of some of the most important
takeaways uh at least for me from the
podcast and I hope you'll find them
helpful as well final quick little
mention before we get onto the episode
itself is you might have known you might
know you might not know that I have
written a book it's called field good
productivity it's about how to do more
of what matters to you it's being
officially published in December of 2023
but if you're watching this before then
then I would love it if you could
pre-order the book please there will be
some really exciting bonuses if you do
pre-order the book because pre-ordering
the book means you be doing me a favor
and it's just great for everything in
terms of book promotion and all that
kind of fun stuff so if you've gotten
value from this podcast or from my
content over the years I'd really
appreciate it if you could pre-order the
book and if you hold on to your email
receipt or physical receipt or whatever
then we'll be announcing more details of
the very exciting bonuses that we've got
coming up just for people who
pre-order okay so let's get on with this
episode so first up we have the money
expert Cody Sanchez and Cody's teaching
us how we can maximize our wealth and
our money over time your first $100,000
comes faster if you earn before you
invest yeah too many people want to take
a dollar and invest it in the stock
market and have a Robin Hood trade do
well for them or a Bitcoin go up or down
or an NF and I think it's completely
wrong you should optimize first we have
a strategy called learn um which is
basically we want you to focus first on
earning money before you do anything and
the reason why is because you can't uh
if you have money it's always easier to
make money rule number one in order to
make money you have to first do the
thing that is easiest and highest Roi
that's typically not going to be that
you put a dollar into the stock market
and it makes you $100,000 but what you
could do is you could negotiate a salary
increase of 5 to 20% each year or buy
annually and you're much more likely to
then be able to invest that money
intelligently but a lot of people you
know instead of first earning and then
learning and then investing they go
invest learn earn and I think that's the
opposite of what we want to do too many
people have seen people make a lot of
money in investing and it's a long game
yeah yeah I think that's so true it's
like
uh sometimes I'll I'll get friends
asking me like hey you know
you're you're into investing like what
should I invest my money in and I'm like
hm the easy answer is S&P 500 but yeah I
I think that's not actually the answer
like what's the goal here let's figure
this out and then you know find out that
oh they'd love to become financially
independent or they'd love to have an
extra ,000 a month to kind of I don't
know go on holiday or whatever the thing
might be and I'm like okay so if we if
we if you continue investing in the S&P
500 you'll get there maybe 30 years from
now yep is that what you want or like
and ultimately what it comes down to is
like increasing your own ability to earn
money whether through investing in your
own business or investing in your own
skills yeah is just way higher Roi then
the 7% returns you'll get by investing
in the top 500 companies in the US 100%
the ROI of you is infinite the ROI of an
investment is capped um and so I think
you want to invest to beat inflation I
mean that's originally why we have
investing is that the C you know the
price of money decreases every single
year due to the government and so we
have to have some sort of investing so
that we our money doesn't get eaten Away
by inflation um that's what we should
expect 7 to 10% per year would be great
if we could do that continuously
anything above and beyond it unless
you're actively involved in the
investment which changes the game uh
isn't going to make you rich it's just
going to make
you be
inflation all right next up we have some
genuinely life-changing advice from
Nicholas Cole who has made millions of
dollars by writing on the internet I
think the skill is ridiculously
important because leveling up my writing
was the main thing that allowed my
YouTube channel to succeed leveling up
my writing is what helped me write this
book and everything that we do in our
business to make the money that we do
and hopefully have the impact that we
have is Downstream of writing and so
this is Cole offering advice on how to
become a successful writer you can make
money as a writer it's just you need to
differentiate between are you saying I
want to write this and then you go out
into the world and go who's willing to
buy it or are you starting in the
opposite direction and go what do you
need what what answer are you looking
for what question do you have and can I
provide it and that was the as soon as I
realized that everything changed and I
went from the fallacy of I'm going to
sit down and write what I want to write
about now I have to go hustle it right
with starting in the inverse who's who's
the reader what do they want I was doing
a session for our YouTuber academy
yesterday where where you know we were
doing like a little Q&A and people are
people always struggle with this
question of what's my Niche mhm and and
one way of approaching it is what do I
want to make videos about but the more
successful way of approaching it is what
do other people want and how can I serve
them yes and just kind of thinking like
an entrepreneur rather than thinking
like a hobbyist who's like hey I I have
all these I have these hundred different
interests I want to make videos about
productivity and Entrepreneurship and
personal development like okay as do
five million other people like come on
where's where is there a market where's
where is there something that we can
serve someone yeah I mean the the
hardest thing I think to wrap your head
around is your Niche is not about you
your Niche is about your reader or your
viewer or your listener so where I
notice a lot of writers go wrong is they
spend their whole lives just going well
I want to write what I want to write
about and you should that's great but
also you are in service of the reader
and I think a really important thing to
differentiate between is if you want to
write whatever you want to write about
go for it like that's the beauty of the
internet that's the beauty of
self-publishing that's you have that
freedom but don't 2 seconds later then
complain when the external result isn't
what you want right so someone goes I
want to write what I want to write about
and then they go and why aren't I going
viral or where's all the money or why
don't I have a gazillion followers right
and that's because you're not being
clear about whether you're doing this
for yourself or you're doing it for an
external outcome and I think you need to
be honest and go
I want a right to make
money great make decisions that unlock
that outcome you know whereas there's a
lot of things that I want to write in my
lifetime that I want to write and I'm
not confused about the fact that those
things are probably maybe it might be a
home run but probably not going to make
as much money as if I start with the end
in mind and go well what does that
person need and how can I use writing to
serve that need you know what I mean
there's this a famous artist um I don't
know if you're famili like um I think
Aziz andari was at a party and he asked
this really big musician who releases
stuff like every like 10 years or
something like that and I'm blanking on
the name but but essentially he asked
him like hey man how like it seems like
you just kind of do whatever you want
you just release music when you want it
seems like you're not caught up in the
trappings of the industry like how do
you do it and the guy was like it's easy
I just make a lot less money and it's
like you know the the the way we teach
this on a YouTuber Academy is I always
say to people that there is a spectrum
between I'm doing this as a hobby and
I'm doing this as a business yes where
are you on that Spectrum from like 0 to
10 and everyone says 10 10 10 10 10 10
otherwise they wouldn't be in the course
whereas when we do our free workshops
everyone's like 2 three4 is like the
average but then the same people that
are like I want to do this 10 out of 10
as a business are still also kind of
still struggling with this thing around
like oh but I have all these 10
different passions and I want to make
videos about all of them whereas you
wouldn't make a a grossery free store
well a a shop trying to a shop trying to
sell absolutely everything because you'd
be competing with Amazon you'd be
finding a niche where you know there's
there is a market for the thing and just
focusing on that even if you have these
other 10 interests yeah I mean the
example I love we use this in uh in our
course ship 30 which is we asked the
question what's Ryan holidays
Niche and immediately the whole chat all
blows up with the same one word right
everyone says stoicism and then I go
okay great how do you know that right
like why did you type that and we don't
realize that we associate niches with
people because they educate us to do
that right it doesn't just happen like
the reason we associate stoicism with
Ryan holiday is because he writes book
after book after book and he makes
YouTube video after YouTube video that
says stoicism right we would not do that
if every single thing he wrote or every
video he created was a different topic
so I think that's point a point B is
realizing that you can do both I it's a
fallacy to think you're a
one-dimensional person you're not we all
have many interests you can do more than
one thing most people don't know that I
have like I don't even know three poetry
books published oh I didn't know that
yeah right most people don't know that
and that's fine because I'm not confused
about which thing I do because I want do
it and which thing I do that is my money
maker that's the whole question is you
want to make the niche if if your goal
is how do I make money right you want to
make the niche you're Money Maker but
that doesn't mean you can't do other
things you can just don't expect those
things to have the same external outcome
as your money maker right and I think
remembering that gives you so much
freedom and it allows you to do all the
things that you want to do and and you
aren't confused about what to optimize
to make sure that you can still put food
on the
table now continuing on the theme of
wealth building and financial
Independence which you know we've done
surveys of a podcast it's the topic that
you guys most want to hear about and
sometimes people are like well you spend
too much time talking about money but
honestly we're all about helping people
build a life they love and money is
honestly probably the single biggest
obstacle to that path but we're now
going to hear from business coach Robin
weight about how to price your business
and there was a lot of takeaways I took
away from this that we've actually
directly applied to our own business
since then just out curiosity if you had
to charge I don't know let's say an
hourly rate for each session over those
12 weeks what would that how much would
you charge that's where I I feel like
there's a a bit of a an a hurdle here in
my mind because like for example I know
I could make £40 an hour by taking an
extra shift at the hospital and so I
feel comfortable charging 440 an hour
for that but when it comes to the
relationship stuff like I don't have any
qualifications yes I've helped my
friends but I feel I'd feel really you
know charging 40 pounds an hour is
charging it to the Healthcare System
it's not charging it to a person so I'd
feel really weird if someone asked me
for my help and I would charge them 40
pounds an hour I I'll share a little
story with you so I met Mrs weight
Charlotte uh through a website called
muddy matches uh 11 years ago money
matches muddy matches muddy matches yeah
we live out in the cost world so it's a
bit yeah very country um so um how much
would I pay to have had the opportunity
to meet my future wife through online
dating and I wasn't particularly good at
the dating game let's be fair um you
can't put a price on that and so I think
where you kind of have looked inside
yourself and kind of looked into your
own value system there and that I'm not
going to give you a therapy session
about around that but um it's common
what people do is they kind of base
their price is based on their own value
system but what you're actually doing
there is you're making a decision on
behalf of everybody else in your world
all of your clients so when you say well
I think I'm only worth 0 an hour you're
kind of making a decis ision on behalf
of all of your clients which might may
or may not be serving them justly
so think about it this way there are
things where maybe if you haven't paid
enough for it do you really value it
that much whereas actually if you've
paid a lot for something do you covet it
cherish it look after it take care of it
think whether if you're capitalistic
expensive cars and things like that like
you get the slightest dinging like oh my
God just ding my car sort of thing so
you really cover things that you're
actually invested and so when it comes
to coaching especially it's much better
to be at the more expensive end of it
because then what you get is clients who
are invested in the process they're more
likely to do the things which you're
encouraging them to do and as a result
of that they're more likely to get
better results right so if you're
charging 5 to 10K for this
transformation program to 10K y we'll
come on to that okay okay so I'm just
this is part of the coaching process
yeah so if you let's say you're charging
5 to 10K for this coaching process
you're going to get very committed
clients but also you don't need that
many clients each to work with each year
in order to build a sustainable
profitable coaching practice 10 clients
a year 20 clients a year and actually
you've got a six figure income bloody
hell right it would take me 10 years of
training in medicine to even approach a
six figer income yeah so and this this
is where a lot of people get business
wrong so um I I want to focus on let's
let's stick with where we're going with
your coaching business for the time
being though coaching practice
so six month transformation we've got
this intensive 12we period you were
thinking well 440 P an hour I was
thinking I was thinking like 10 quid an
hour because I'm like what the hell do I
know about this okay well okay even at1
pound an hour so for a weekly session
say which is an hour plus all the
different touch points but you you're
talking there of like charging like I
don't know 200 quid for2 200 pound for
like a program six-month program right
yeah if you think about it yeah that's
pretty cheap okay yeah so this is where
we we break into like people see pricing
as um binary okay so binary thinking so
it's either yes or no I'm in or I'm out
it's too cheap or it's too expensive
okay yep right and at200 I think you
probably well your face said that's too
cheap I can't believe I was going to
charge that much for my time I'm worth
more than that yeah you'd earn more than
that as a yeah I could make more I can
make that in one shift and then when I
said 5 to 10K your eyes popped out of
your head you know across the table and
and so but what we've got now is we've
got 4,800 numbers between 200 and 5,000
okay and there's there's a a future
version of Aly that's again selling his
coaching um program for 5K Maybe not
today but in the future yeah so we we
can do do you want we can do you've seen
me do this before I think Ally but the
Jedi mind trick do you want to play a
Jedi let's play the Jedi mind trick play
the Jedi mind trick game okay so let's
start at 200 pound and the reason I do
this exercise well I I'll explain it
afterwards a okaye we're going to figure
out um what level you need to be selling
this at as of today if you going to step
out and work with your first coaching
client okay so200 500 for for the six
months yeah for the six months £500 £800
12,200 already KY 1,200 grade yeah so
you're so you're you're everybody has a
poker face right for whatever so
whenever so initially when you were
trying to figure this out how much you
should charge in the structure of your
program and what am I worth you're
trying to solve it intellectually yeah
okay and we all know you have without
going too woo woo you have more than one
brain okay um our subconscious brain is
very intuitive and so um that's why
intellectually were like 200 pounds but
when we started to look into your
subconscious of where you actually truly
value yourself you're like well 1,200
well it was between 800 and £1,200 where
Pokerface came out and you couldn't keep
a straight face and I knew that that's
where your subconscious was telling you
even now as you say 1200 I'm just like I
I find myself just not being able to
keep a straight so was 800
comfortable you're not disagreeing with
me so so what we want to do is we want
we don't want to stay in Comfort Zone
because we don't actually learn that
much in there you've got to stretch
yourself a little bit so my advice would
actually be if you were going to go out
and sell this hypothetical coaching
program sure you go and Pitch 10 to 20
people at ,200 for that six-month
transformation process and I I know
because I've done this with 700 over 700
business owners now um the pricing thing
that is get people to elevate their
prices I know that um a good conversion
rate for most businesses like coaching
is somewhere around about 1 in5 to 1 in
three let's round the numbers call it 20
to 40% really so yeah so if you pitch 10
people high uh it's it's not actually
it's 20% so one in five is actually
quite it's quite low a lot of people
think it's quite low but like how if I
if I think of like people that I know at
work they they they wouldn't pay £1,000
1,200 quid for like maybe they're not
your ideal
audience ah okay cuz how do I find my
ideal or are we going to come to that we
we can do but um yeah uh the other way
to look at it as well is um again people
approach us from the wrong way around
they go I'm going to build my product
and then hope that people come and buy
it right yeah what we actually want to
do is we want to come from the other the
other end of the spectrum okay so if
your goal was to um make 100k from your
coaching business 100K damn okay yeah
right so but let's okay what what would
your goal be if you were starting from
scr you're going to give this a shot if
I can make 2K a month so that's like 24K
month 24K a year okay so now what we do
is we take 24K we divide it by 1,200
pounds and it's roughly 20 clients yeah
yeah if I had 20 clients could you
service 20 clients do you have the
capacity to work with 20 clients over
the course of a year so if it's weekly
calls that would be 20 hours a week 20
hours a week that's quite a lot there's
a lot coaching very energetic I don't
know if I'd be I'd have the time to do
that so how many could you do you think
work with Okay let think about this so
you know I work Monday to Friday then
some weekends and night shifts and stuff
so if I had flexibility on one I could
book them because my roto is
weird I think I could do five five a
week five calls a week probably because
that's like one a day on average yeah so
so what we've done is this this called
capacity based pricing right so you work
out your your end goal for your business
what's what how much money do I want to
make basically very simple terms and we
divide it by the price that we've kind
of come to a conclusion this is roughly
what I think we should be charging
but now we've got a gap so if you only
get five clients concurrently um which
probably means like 10 clients
throughout the year because you're going
to get a little bit of overlap bit of
churn some clients leaving they meet
their future wife husband whatever and
they don't need your help anymore maybe
they come back when they've got
relationship problems further down the
line I don't know um but so 10 clients
say so actually what we've established
is that you're going to fall short of
your financial goal because you don't
have the capacity to service 24,000
worth of business okay so good point Y
the real price
that yeah so so this is so capacity has
a m a go your goal is important capacity
has a major part to play especially if
you're setting this up as like a side
hustle yeah alongside a full-time job um
so now we've got a a difficult decision
here we go well £1,200 I know that was
going to be a bit of a stretch but if
some can afford 12200 could they afford
2 and a half K probably over six months
don't forget if I could get people at 2
and a half K that would mean I would
only need 10 clients in the whole year
yes
and you could go down to three days a
week and then yeah I feel emotional just
thinking about it and I'm not even like
faking here I'm just like just sort of
imagining myself in that position yeah
if I break the fourth wall a moment I'm
just like oh my goodness that would
actually be transformational but I have
all these spheres coming up around like
charging 2500 and even how do I find
these 10 people forget forget about the
money forget about the money can you can
you visualize yourself working with
those people and transform their lives
yes okay yeah can you do you feel
confident enough in your ability to
deliver like such remarkable results for
them that you'd have no problem
refunding them if they had if they
didn't get if they didn't meet the love
of their life and they say they Ally
this is rubbish you didn't you didn't
find the love of my life I want to
refund would you have any problem
refunding them if they did the work then
no if they didn't do the work then well
they didn't do the work okay well let
let's assume they did the work you threw
everything at it best will in the world
didn't get the results no they can have
a full refund I I don't want their money
if they don't get the result yeah 100%
says no you deris it there's no Jeopardy
here what do you mean oh okay like if
someone doesn't if someone doesn't get
the result yeah I can just give them
give them give them their money
back provided they've and this is where
the contract comes in okay so the
contracts States you got to show up to
all of the calls you've got to do all of
the homework you've got to go on the
dates etc etc and if they do that and if
they do that I mean they're basically
going to find find a relationship and if
they don't then I I'll happily refund
them sure this episode is very kindly
brought to you by hu I've been using hu
I've been a Pay customer of hu since
2017 since my fifth year of medical
school when I first discovered it and
basically what it is if you haven't
heard heard of it is that it is a meal
in a shake it's got the perfect balance
of carbs and fiber and proteins and fat
and it contains 26 different vitamins
and minerals all you do is add water or
milk to the powder usually I use water
you can shake it up or you can blend it
I prefer to blend and then it becomes a
fantastic option if you're like me and
you're kind of busy and so you don't
really have time for breakfast or lunch
my favorite version is the heel black
edition it's absolutely sick 400
calories 40 g of protein for 400
calories I'm trying to get Hench and
it's actually pretty hard to find
something that has such a high protein
content for such a low calorie trade-off
and so I really like using the Hu Black
Edition to start my mornings off it's
vegan it's gluten free it's lactose free
the Black Edition is available in nine
flavors my favorite is salted caramel
and I wouldn't recommend having every
single meal heal because that gets a bit
annoying after a while but it's
absolutely fantastic as like one of the
meals of the day especially if you're
busy and you're going to kind of default
to something unhealthy otherwise it's
also very affordable so it actually
works out to £168 per meal for a 400
calorie meal which is just incredible
value and actually way cheaper than
other generic protein shakes on the
market and it saves a bunch of time
because it's so quick and easy to make
and so it's particularly exciting that
the sponsoring the podcast and actually
we had the founder of hu Julian Hearn
who was on the very first season of the
podcast that was a sick episode that got
so many R reviews as well anyway if you
interested in trying out hu then head
over to hu.com deepdive and if you use
that URL a it really helps me out but B
you also get a free t-shirt and also a
free Shaker that comes with your order
so go to heel.com deepdive that'll also
be linked down in the video description
or the show notes and thank you so much
heel for sponsoring this episode this
episode is very kindly brought to you by
trading 212 now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing cuz I've
made a bunch of videos about it on the
YouTube channel and my advice for most
people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212 it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested £100 into this thing what
would my return have been X weeks or X
months further down the line once you've
got some comfort with that then it's
super easy to deposit money into your
trading 212 account you can use Apple
pay like I do initially or you can use a
direct bank transfer and then once the
money is in your trading 212 account
then you can invest it in basically
whatever you want now if you're based in
the UK you might be familiar with the
concept of an Isa which is an individual
savings account which is basically a
tax-free rapper that you can put money
in you can put £20,000 in every year up
to £20,000 and it resets every April and
then all that money can grow and it's
completely taxfree for the rest of your
life and if you want to sign up for an
iso you can sign up for one completely
for free also on trading 212 so if you
haven't yet filled up your Isa allowance
or at least put some money into your Isa
for this year that might be a good step
forward also very excitingly there's a
new feature that they've added to the
app which is a daily interest on your
uninvested cash these interest rates may
go up or down over time as the economic
environment changes but the cool thing
is that you get paid out every single
day if you're into that sort of thing
the app also lets you Auto invest which
is a great thing because then you can
automatically invest a percentage of
your paycheck into the thing every month
and so if you haven't yet started with
investing and you want to give it a go
then you can download the app on the App
Store and if you use the coupon code Ali
that will give you a totally free share
worth up to £100 it's available on
iPhone and Android and you can check it
out by typing in trading212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading 212 for sponsoring this
episode all right changing gears for
money we now have Dr Alex George who is
a fellow medical doctor and who also
specializes in public health advice as
it relates to mental health and so this
is Dr Alex George and I discussing how
to set boundaries with other people and
a great catchphrase and I talk about in
the mind manual about having ways to
deal with um situations where you need
boundaries so I've been six months sober
or six months alcohol free as of
yesterday which I'm proud of um
important to say I don't have addiction
I'm speaking from perspective I made a
Health Choice I don't I don't compare
myself to those that suffer from
addiction it is very much you know um
something that I decided to do because I
felt that I'd be happier without it and
healthier and so on but it's still a
challenge it's still hard not to drink
because the society is kind of
constructed around the consumption of
alcohol almost in every different facet
and way and ironically if you're trying
to be productive probably the biggest
thing that will be stopping you
achieving your goals would be alcohol
you know almost for every single person
if you drink alcohol and you want to do
one thing to improve your productivity
outcomes your health your relationships
your Fitness anything just stop drinking
it's one of the best things that you can
do but people ask you to drink all the
time so having an anchor phrase is
really useful and sometimes even just an
awareness of how you're going to respond
to that like people go and say Alex do
you want a drink I just say I don't
drink but thank you or I go say what
would you like a drink and we say at the
bar say we are at restaurant what would
you like to drink I'd say I'd like to
have um a whatever name of the drink it
might be it might be sparkling water or
I want whatever it is don't allow for
space of conversation if you don't want
to have that around drinking and if
someone questions you and says oh do you
not drink say oh no I don't drink if you
don't create space for the conversation
it doesn't happen some people will be
curious because they're so curious and
say oh that's really interesting how
come you stop drinking and then you can
have that conversation if you'd like to
but have boundaries over what you share
you don't have to to explain away
everything in the same way if someone
says um Ali I'd love you to come to uh
the this restaurant next week we're
going to have a dinner say oh thank you
so much I really appreciate asking but
not this time we'll do it another time
or just no thank you you don't have to
give excuses and often when you give
excuses it just feels so inauthentic
it's not authentic just say you don't
want to it's fine your time is precious
and it is the key word is your time to
spend it in the way that you want to but
a great anchor phrase I find for work
stuff and and I don't know what you use
but you know I get asked to do lots of
different things if I am absolutely
certain in my gut that it's the right
thing to do I'll say yes to it but if
there is even a Shadow of Doubt that I
think this might not be the right thing
to do I need to think on it I say ask me
in 24 hours you Abby sat in the room
here my my um EA and I say to ask me in
24 hours she puts it 24 hours next to
whatever the question is and she ask me
again tomorrow allows your brain time to
think about am I making a reactionary
decision yeah or am I or am I actually
uncomfortable with this another piece of
advice I'd give is never make never make
an important decision in fact if you can
avoid any decision from a position where
You' just achieved something or
succeeded or won something or something
you've really lost or something bad
that's happened if you're in a high of
success you'll often take on more things
because your endorphins are pumping
you're like oh you know what um I've
done this Masters let's do a
PhD don't make a decision once you've
just achieved something also never make
a decision when you're really from A
Loss when things have gone wrong we have
a context of like again going back to
that point this is forever this
suffering this pain this awfulness is
forever you're much more likely to make
a bad decision allow breathing spaces
most things do not have to be decided in
the moment you're in other than what
kind of coffee do you want to drink when
you stood in the cafe most things can
have time you don't have to commit to
things too quickly yeah the boundary
thing is something I I struggle with so
much why do you struggle with that I
thought I I'm surprised you say that
because given how much you talk about
this I'm surprised it's very honest of
you to share it but I'm surprised that
you struggle with I think uh cuz I have
a people pleasing tendency and so
whenever someone asks me something if
they're asking me in person or even
often if they're asking me on message
and it's someone that I know in some way
personally I will feel this strong comp
compulsion to say yes to the thing can I
give you a phrase that will help please
I would love yeah any tips I'm at
capacity it's one of the best phrases
you can use that I think is pretty well
understood by everyone
andac theyy
itely and iuse that phrase and I've had
DMS from people I just say I'm really
sorry that sounds brilliant I don't even
say I a lot I don't say I'm sorry
anymore I say you know thanks so much
for asking I really appreciate but I'm
at capacity at the moment or capacity
how would you use it CU it's you can't
be offended by that how can you be
offended by someone saying they're at
capacity back capacity means you can't
take more and I think people really
understand that I found no one has ever
come back and said oh well no one has
ever done that I'm at capacity and you
know what there you go you said about
your therapy that's a great thing to why
are you people pleaser yeah all of that
stuff I think where where you why do you
think you're a people pleaser I've been
reading a good book called No More Mr
Nice Guy uh which is very good it's
written by some therapist who deals with
sort of people pleasing tendencies in
men and that book just speaks to me so
much CU he talks about how how a lot of
uh Early Childhood experiences or can
contribute to a child feeling as if
they're not enough as they are and they
have to perform or they do something or
get that perfect grade or whatever and
then that cycle of perfectionism becomes
part of their being and so when someone
asks you for something you're like oh
yeah you know I I want to be a good
person a good person says yes to things
and is not selfish and any amount of
self-care gets read as selfish and
selfish is seen as bad and so all of
these different patterns add up to
create this feeling of H yeah I'm going
to say yes even though I don't really
want to say yes to the thing it's uh
it's something that is shared by a lot
of people actually I think and um you
know you're right so much of it's from
childhood I I had Parents um I think
it's fair to say my dad was quite strict
um I was the first I was the first child
I think my parents were kind of from
that area and I grew up in I guess '90s
early 2000s when I think it was kind of
strict Parenthood it was that kind of
time um success means doing well at
school and yeah I had the same feeling I
think you know our perfectionism wanting
to be the best anything from the best
but the best is not great and worst of
all it's actually terrible if you're not
the best and I've very much unlearned
those things but it's taken a lot of
work and I still come those Tendencies
often still come back at times and I
have to go oh actually where does that
come from why am I feeling that way and
actually can make you um it can make you
feel two things number one that if you
don't agree to do something because
someone's asked you do it that you're a
bad person you're a failure but also can
make you really start comparing to
others and thinking well if I'm not
doing as much as that person or that
person that I'm not successful I mean
one of the things I think is fascinating
is that we slightly not patronizingly
but we slightly go on social media yeah
B um comparison culture and social media
just about body images and six-pack it
isn't is it you speak to a lot of um
professionals they'll go oh yeah but you
know I feel compar you know I had a
psychiatrist tell me a few months ago um
I obviously want to say who it was said
they find it really hard and find it
triggering online because I see other
consultant psychiatrist presenting more
papers or doing more conferences or
writing or you know getting published in
this article so you know we are a little
bit like oh it's about flash cars and
sixpacks yeah there are it is comparison
is about every metric of comparison to
be human is to compare so we'll compare
anything um yeah but actually it's a
huge thing in in in the workspace as
well productivity I mean there's a huge
balance of productivity and what's
productive what's toxic what's you know
if you're sharing doing a run at 5:30 in
the morning are you sharing that because
you're celebrating Within yourself or
you just sharing because you're showing
other people that you're doing at 5:30
in the morning and what impact does that
have on other people and I'm not saying
it's wrong I mean there's so many ways
and I share things like okay I shared
the my children's book one children
children's book of the Year why am I
sharing that you could dig into all
these things you know I'm very proud
that I I sh I that I that I did that and
so on but there is a we have to think a
little bit sometimes about why we're
posting stuff but also if we're seeing
something if we're reacting negatively
why are we doing that because sometimes
you know someone's posted something with
the best intentions but it's had a
negative effect on you that person's not
trying to have a negative effect on you
you got to work out why where does your
reaction come from is it because you're
now beating yourself up because you
didn't work harder on something when
actually you're already doing so much I
I think that that's really important
part of boundaries in life is around all
that stuff there also a social media I
mean the average person spends between
three and four hours day on social media
that's a huge amount of time make sure
you you'll know why you're using it's
the first thing like like you know if
it's to make yourself laugh that is a
valid reason but just know what reason
it is doesn't have to I'm using it to
propel my business into stardom it can
just be want to giggle looking at cats
that are don't know whatever cat videos
dog videos whatever it is doesn't matter
just know while you're using it don't
get sucked into it and also just be
careful if you're having negative
reactions to stuff then you know
moderate who you follow call your
following you know if you're following
people that trigger you don't follow
them like follow people that inspire you
probably one of the biggest things I'll
say you know how often do you do people
open up their phones in the morning and
get triggered by something you know
great
boundaries and finally what's the point
of all this stuff what's the point of
making all this money and having a
business and all this stuff if we can't
share life with the people that matter
most to us and so this is a snippet of
the conversation between me and Jemma
span who is the host of the psychology
of your 20s podcast and we're talking
about how to maintain friendships when
life gets super busy especially as an
adult when we're in school or university
friendship Galore like you live next to
people everything's all good so fun but
then people graduate they get jobs
friends move away everyone gets busy and
it seems like even if you're living in
the same city like I'm now living in
London like literally all of my friends
with the exception of a handful of uh
friends who are doctors who are moved to
different parts of the world um all my
friends are in London and yet it still
feels like I see my school friends once
every six months once a year because
even though the we're in London just
sort of getting the calendars to line up
and schedules to line up and all that
kind of stuff plus the fact that it
usually needs one person to take the
initiative and if everyone's busy no one
does that have you got any tips or best
practices or habits for um maintaining
or building new friendships Post
University yes so I'm going to I'm going
to offer you two here perfect the first
one is around those pre-existing
relationships I truly believe that you
should be the person to take
initiative if you want something if you
want to see these people if those
relationships are kind of falling apart
like be be the person person be the
person who takes initiative it can take
a lot of energy but I'm that person in
in in my friendship groups and I'll do
things like let's one of them is I do a
Sunday dinner so every Sunday when I'm
in town I say to anyone who lives in
Sydney who I know come for dinner just
bring a bottle of wine bring dessert
bring something and have a feed and just
let me know like 4 hours in advance if
you're coming along bring Partners bring
anyone and that Sunday dinner is
actually such like is like the glue
for some of my relationships and not to
say that like those people are only
coming for the free food but they're so
busy that having a discret day where I
know that we're going to see each other
actually is a lot easier for a lot of
people to to navigate with such busy
lives um so that's actually a a tip I
wouldn't say a habit but a tip um if you
can afford to do it if you have the time
make the initiative something like a
Sunday dinner or like a Saturday brunch
Club is like a great kind of um activity
to bring people together and the the
other habit that I think is really
important is to be consistent in your
hobbies and your activities if you're
looking to make new friends so I think
this applies to a lot of people in their
20s I moved to a new city um like almost
two years ago year and a half ago and I
left behind this whole community that I
had and I felt like I was starting from
scratch and the best thing that I did
was invest time in consistently going to
the same activities and the same Hobbies
week in week out and those were cycling
classes and rock
climbing when you go to the same
location and do the same thing in the
same building it's likely that the same
people are going to be there and it's
likely that you already have something
in common that you can Bond over and
similarity we know is the biggest
biggest determinant of friendship
similarity and proximity and then
reciprocity so you kind of already have
those two down right similarity you're
doing an activity that you know the
people people in that room already lag
and proximity you're going to see these
people week and week out if they also
are showing up consistently at the
activities that you're doing I made so
many friends that way because you start
to become familiar faces in each other's
lives to strike up a conversation next
thing you know are you coming next week
yeah I am we should get a coffee
beforehand boom friendship nice that's a
that's a really big habit that I and a
habit but also a tip that I think is so
valuable if you want to make new friends
is to show up in the same places at the
same time and I'm sure that the people
that you actually find yourself really
being aligned to will be the people who
are doing the same thing does that make
sense yeah that's such a good idea yeah
yeah I think
like I feel like one of the one of one
of the things about University and why
people often end up making friends with
the people that they live next to it's
just that proximity thing and it's less
about quality time and more about
quantity time oh yeah and so showing up
to the same activ like I I started
kickboxing lessons a few months ago but
I've really half asked it and I haven't
shown up to the group classes
consistently and therefore there's no
chance I'm going to make friends with
anyone there but if I just showed up for
like a few weeks in a row chances are I
would have made friends with at least
one person there and like you know they
go to the pub afterwards and you join
them and then that's how friendships are
formed whereas oh I'm so I'm too busy
this week because work and I'm too busy
that week because work and I'm too busy
that because other plans now it makes it
a lot harder to make friends in that
specific setting yeah well the other one
that's really good is um sports games so
like sports games I do that sounds so
naive but matches but uh sports team so
I joined my footall team like a footall
team that was great what team a footall
it's like indoor soccer foot yeah it's
indoor soccer in Australia cool do you
guys not have that here I mean we call
it indoor football but we don't have a
prop name for it yeah wait that's we
don't have football and you call it
soccer yeah soccer indoor soccer so that
was great and I also think another habit
it that it's also aligned to this idea
of making friends um that I think anyone
needs to form whether you are in your
teens or your 20s or your 30s that is
active listening active listening is
such an attractive quality in any friend
any partner any workmate any
acquaintance so you want to possess that
as well and I think that it's a skill
that takes time so practicing
actually listening to what people are
saying acknowledging how their body is
reacting to you trying to and it comes
naturally over time I think we're
actually not inherently great listeners
this in this generation because we're so
bombarded by all the stimulus and all
these things going on in our brain and
in our environment that sometimes these
kinds of conversations the on that we're
having right now um Can it can be very
hard to engage in them so practice
active listening practice actually
making eye contact with someone trying
to imagine what they're what they're
feeling what they're thinking and engage
with what they're saying to you and
reciprocate that I think that when we
talk about relationships in our 20
whatever that may be being an active
listener makes you um an attractive
person to have a relation relationship
with someone who's enjoyable to be
around and it just causes all of our
relationships to to
flourish any tips for active listening
um so I I think that I realized that I
wasn't a great active listener and um
someone gave me this tip was to really
look at okay I'm going to act well
you're not talking but I'm going to
pretend that I'm active listening to you
right now is to really like look at
someone and be and and really try and
sit in their words and picture their
words and imagine what they're saying so
instead of just being like oh this is
just stuff that's coming into my ear
like really imagine that you're in their
stories with them and that visualization
will it will make you more engaged a but
it will make you seem more engaged
because you are um the other thing to do
I think active listening is not just
about what's coming out verbally it's
also about someone's body and really
taking time to acknowledge okay I we all
kind of understand various body cues
actually recognize them and pick up on
how's this person feeling and can I make
them more comfortable or um how am I
acting right now and is that making them
uncomfortable or is it making them feel
safe so all of those two kind of things
to to understand and and to get further
into what someone else is telling you I
think is important and and it is just a
go I
think yeah one one uh one thing I was
researching for my book was you know
what are the differences between
energizing relationships and draining
relationships I love this concept and
one of the key things that came up in in
the in the studies that I was looking at
was um the idea of uh energizing
responses so for example if someone
shares news then there's sort of four
different ways to respond to that and
the two main axes for that are is it
active or passive and is it constructive
or destr constuctive so active
constructive is where we kind of want to
be for the most energizing relationships
which is you know you you say you've
just run a half marathon or whatever and
an active constructive response might be
oh my God that's incredible tell me more
about how did it feel and it's like I'm
building on it and asking you to share
more that's so good a a passive
constructive response would be oh that's
cool yeah passive I mean it's
constructive in that I haven't like torn
you down for it but it's not that
energizing it's sort of neutral at best
a passive d RVE response would be um
kind of oh cool but let me tell you
about the thing that I did where it's
like kind of the self-centered thing and
then an active destructive response is a
total dick whereas someone's like well
that's not such a big deal like blah
blah blah blah blah blah like why would
you think you should do that you're
going to ruin your knees that would just
be a completely unhelpful response yeah
and shifting more towards energizing
interactions active constructive
responses to things there's like genuine
evidence from like psychology studies
that people who do that are seen as more
energizing more charismatic more
enjoyable to be around than people that
respond in any of the other three ways
it's so powerful isn't it and it's um
the one that you said uh it's active no
passive constructive is that it where
someone's like oh that's cool yeah isn't
that the worst I honestly think that
that's worse than someone being like oh
cool but guess what I did I like and
especially when you share news with with
um friends or family and I think those
are the people that we love the most and
we trust the most and we want them to be
like really corner but then you have to
remember that the reaction that you want
from someone else you need to give them
as well so anytime someone gives you
really great news like you need like you
should be genuinely excited for them if
they're someone that you care about or
someone that you like or someone that
you know I think that's so valuable just
reciprocating good energy from the
people that you want in your life is so
powerful in our 20s all right that's it
for the Roundup and that's the official
end of season 6 of The Deep dive podcast
I really hope you got some value from
some of the episodes in this season or
maybe even from the back catalog because
a lot of the episodes that we've
released in previous seasons are still
very relevant today in fact all of them
basically are I'd love for you to join
our free telegram Community the Deep
divers if you're potentially interested
and if you happen to be watching this on
YouTube I would love for you to leave a
comment down below if you're still here
and firstly thank you for watching um
but I'd love for you to leave a comment
Down Below on this YouTube video and
sharing what's one thing that you really
like about the podcast and what's one
thing you'd like to really see more of
that really really really helps us
figure out what guests to invite on for
the next seasons how to structure the
episodes so we really want to hear more
from you guys who are very kind enough
to watch and listen to the podcast to
help us figure out how do we make this
even better so that's it for me for now
and hopefully I will see you in the next
season bye-bye